music mogul Russell Simmons is strongly
denying new accusations that he raped
three women decades ago the New York
Times reports the alleged assaults took
place at Simmons apartment in the 80s
and the 90s all three women say their
music industry careers were derailed or
ruined Simmons says he categorically
rejects the allegations he calls them
frivolous and hurtful at least 12 women
have now accused Simmons of sexual
misconduct new york times culture
reporter milena Isaiah co-authored the
artal article milena good morning
running I know you call Simmons a
powerful industry gatekeeper in this
article it's not one of the reasons
these women have just come forward now
absolutely he was a powerful figure then
and he remains a powerful figure
now he's somebody who could make her
break careers and you know he touched a
lot of industries he had a very wide
sway so I think that for these women
coming forward took a lot of courage and
a lot of time thinking about what they
wanted to say and how they wanted to say
it on the record accusing him of rape
absolutely I mean you know many of these
accounts took place many years ago so
they've been living with this pain for a
long time did he have around him this
kind of apparatus that Harvey Weinstein
had that others had that kind of knew
this happened and took care of it and
protected him in this kind of behavior I
think they were probably whispers
certainly in the industry about this you
know but many of these things happens
you know in his apartment he took care
to make sure that he was alone in these
moments he often told people he was
inviting them for a party and when they
showed up there was nobody else there so
he had his own methods to make sure that
people stayed quiet as you know Russell
has russell simmons has denied the
allegations in your paper but he says
this the presumption of innocence until
proven guilty
must not be replaced by guilty by
accusation so how did number one did you
reach out to him what was his response
to you on the record and how do you
decide what allegations to print in this
particular cases absolutely we always
reach out to the subjects of these
stories to give them ample time for
comment we tell them what the
allegations are in great detail and he
did you know give us a statement his
lawyer also denied some of these
accusations I will say that he admitted
to one
count of sexual harassment I got a
sexually harassing a woman who worked
with him at def jam he admitted that he
behaved inappropriately there and for us
these stories you know we are very
careful about how we report them we
always talk to people to confirm the
account you know people that the the
women the victims of these this behavior
might have told at the moment they're
friends they're therapists you know
they're partners and so we're able to
kind of confirm this this information
you know as much as possible it's very
important for us to vet this stuff his
career has flourished what happened to
their careers I think that's one of the
most heartbreaking parts of this story
where you see really step-by-step how
experiences like this can undermine
women can undercut their ambition and
you know their careers they felt we're
derailed by this behavior their personal
lives were touched it's a very powerful
thing to go through
well milena Raisa akin credible
reporting that you've done here in The
Times thank you so much for joining us
thank you